Amigos, Venezuela vive en una crisis
permanente y muchos estaréis pensando.
¡Pues vaya novedad! Cierto es que en este
canal ya hemos dedicado muchos vídeos a
este país latinoamericano y desde luego
se puede decir que sus crisis política,
económica y humanitaria
están más que documentadas.
En los últimos años, por ejemplo,
nos hemos centrado en el continuo
tira y afloja entre el chavismo y la
oposición cuando la lideraba Juan Guaidó.
También en el narcoestado dirigido por Diosdado
Cabello y en el colapso económico permanente en
el que vive el país. Pero hoy vamos a hablaros
de algo nuevo y totalmente diferente. De otra
de las graves consecuencias de la revolución
bolivariana. Vamos a hablaros del ecocidio
que se está produciendo en Venezuela.
Sí habéis oído bien: ecocidio. Y no
porque lo digamos nosotros, ni ningún
sicario del imperialismo. Es que así
lo llama el mismísimo presidente Nicolás Maduro.
(“Y nosotros estamos obligados a liberar todos los
parques nacionales del estado Bolívar y todas
las regiones mineras. A liberarlas de mafias
ecocidas. Porque es un ecocidio lo que se
está cometiendo allí; ¡es un ecocidio!”)
La minería ilegal está provocando graves daños
en la Amazonía que pertenece a Venezuela. Pero
esperad un momento, porque la crisis que vive
el país también está causando problemas a la
petrolera estatal PDVSA, con consecuencias
muy graves para el medioambiente. Así que la
pregunta es: ¿Qué está pasando con PDVSA?
¿Quién está detrás de la minería ilegal?
Y una cuestión también importante. . ¿Qué
consecuencias está teniendo todo esto para
las riquezas naturales de Venezuela?
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a responder
a estas preguntas. Pero antes,
vamos a ver un poco de Historia.
T1(LA GRAN VENEZUELA)
El pasado diciembre se cumplieron 100 años
del primer gran descubrimiento de petróleo
en Venezuela. En un principio la producción era
realizada por empresas extranjeras. La Ley de
Hidrocarburos de 1943 ya les obligó a entregar
el 50% de sus ganancias al Estado venezolano.
El oro negro trajo mucha riqueza al país: por
aquel entonces Venezuela era el tercer mayor
productor mundial de petróleo, solo por detrás
de la Unión Soviética y de Estados Unidos. Pero
también hizo a la economía venezolana dependiente
del precio del petróleo. La caída constante del
precio del zumo de dinosaurio empujó a
Venezuela a unirse a varios países de
Oriente Próximo para fundar la Organización
de Países Exportadores de Petróleo en 1960.
(La posición de la OPEP en la crisis del
petróleo de 1973 cuadriplicó los precios
del crudo. Venezuela aprovechó este auge
para registrar el PIB per cápita más alto
de América Latina durante los años 70.
El entonces presidente Carlos Andrés
Pérez anunció triunfalmente la llegada de “La
Gran Venezuela”, que utilizaría la riqueza del
petróleo para desarrollar aún más la nación. Uno
de los primeros pasos fue disminuir la dependencia
de las operaciones de compañías petroleras
extranjeras, nacionalizando la industria
a través de la creación de PDVSA en 1976.)
La nacionalización de la industria petrolera
tuvo unos daños controlados. Si bien en Venezuela
ya se habían llegado a producir 3,5 millones de
barriles de petróleo diarios, PDVSA tuvo un
éxito notable, alcanzando una producción de
2,3 millones de barriles diarios durante
sus primeros cuatro años de operaciones.
Incluso, a finales de los 90, cuando la
corrupción ya campaba a sus anchas por la
política venezolana, PDVSA se aproximó a
niveles récord de producción con casi 3,3
millones de barriles. Sin embargo, amigos,
esta bonanza no se aprovechó como es debido.
El fracaso de Venezuela para frenar la corrupción
y reinvertir los ingresos del petróleo en una
economía más diversificada sentó las bases
para la caída de la economía venezolana.
Y ya tenía bastantes problemas el país y su
industria petrolera cuando en 1999 llegó al
poder el comandante Hugo Chávez. Trajo una
nueva forma de hacer política: el chavismo;
un estilo autoritario y populista que tenía
partidarios pero también muchos detractores.
En 2002 se convocó una huelga nacional para
reclamar elecciones. Tuvo un gran seguimiento
en PDVSA. Llegaron a reducir la producción de
petróleo de los 3 millones diarios a 50.000
barriles. Chávez contraatacó despidiendo a 18.000
empleados de PDVSA, casi la mitad del personal
total de la empresa. Los reemplazó con gente que
no tenía ni idea del sector petrolero pero que
sí eran leales al régimen. Y así ha funcionado
recursos humanos de PDVSA desde entonces. Mirad:
N1(Maduro designa a primo de Chávez presidente
de filial de PDVSA en EE. UU. DW)Esto es como
cuando el Barça quiso reemplazar a Messi y
Luis Suárez con… Bueno, poned vosotros los
nombres que viene a dar lo mismo. Los nuevos
jugadores pueden ocupar el mismo puesto,
pero obviamente no te dan los mismos resultados.
Pues en PDVSA pasó exactamente lo mismo.
Nunca se recuperaron de aquella pérdida
de talento. Venezuela nunca más alcanzó
su objetivo de producción de 3,5 millones de
barriles. Y el golpe definitivo al sector lo
dio Chávez en 2007 cuando ordenó la expropiación
de los activos de ExxonMobil y ConocoPhillips.
Estas empresas habían sido contratadas para
desarrollar la Faja del Orinoco, que contiene
reservas de petróleo crudo extrapesado. Unas
reservas enormes pero difíciles de procesar.
La expropiación a las petroleras estadounidenses
provocó una fuga de capital extranjero, lo que
dejó a Venezuela incapaz de acceder eficientemente
a gran parte de sus reservas de crudo pesado. ¿Y
en qué se tradujo todo esto? Os lo podría contar,
pero casi mejor que lo veáis por vosotros mismos.
La producción de petróleo de Venezuela se mantuvo
en torno a los 3 millones de barriles durante
prácticamente una década. Pero en cuanto empezó a
bajar en 2014 el precio del crudo en los mercados
internaciones, al régimen chavista empezaron a
faltarle los dólares necesarios para mantener en
buenas condiciones de operación sus yacimientos.
¿El resultado? Hoy las nstalaciones de PDVSA se
caen a pedazos. Sus oleoductos están deteriorados
después de estar años y años operando sin ser
revisados. Todo se ha quedado anticuado. El
declive de la petrolera estatal es evidente:
PDVSA ha caído al fondo de un pozo del que le
costará salir. Y hay dos víctimas que están
pagando las consecuencias: la primera víctima
es muy evidente: el medioambiente venezolano.
(Entre 2010 y 2016 PDVSA informó de que se
habían producido 46.000 derrames de petróleo
en sus operaciones, una media de 18 al día.
Desde entonces se niegan a facilitar datos así,
pero no hay nada que indique que la situación
haya mejorado. Los trabajadores aseguran que los
incendios y las explosiones en las refinerías son
relativamente comunes, al igual que las tuberías
rotas y los derrames. Y la petrolera estatal
atraviesa por una situación aún más comprometida
desde que Estados Unidos aplicó sanciones al
petróleo de PDVSA como castigo al chavismo tras
el reconocimiento de Juan Guaidó como presidente.)
La propia PDVSA estima que necesitaría invertir
unos 8.000 millones de dólares para actualizar su
infraestructura de oleoductos y volver a alcanzar
su récord de producción de hace 25 años. Mientras
tanto, continúan los derrames, derrochando el
oro negro y contaminando las aguas costeras y
fluviales. Otro tanto sucede con la quema de
gas natural en los pozos de petróleo. Un
sector energético eficiente intentaría
extraer este gas para aprovecharlo.
Pero claro, eso requeriría tener
una infraestructura adecuada,
unos gasoductos en condiciones…
Pues bien, como Venezuela no tiene nada de
eso, PDVSA se está dedicando a quemarlo.
Obviamente, lo hacen por motivos de
seguridad, pero esto es un problemón
medioambiental porque aumenta las emisiones
de CO2 y de metano. ¿Qué están haciendo para
solucionarlo? Pues más bien nada, porque
en PDVSA están ocupados con otras cosas.
(Exclusiva: Intermediarios han dejado a
la venezolana PDVSA con 21.200 millones
de dólares en facturas impagadas. Reuters)
Algunas estimaciones cifran el saqueo de
PDVSA en 100.000 millones de dólares.
Así que, efectivamente, la segunda
víctima de la mala gestión de la petrolera
estatal es la propia economía venezolana.
Hace 10 años las exportaciones de petróleo
suponían el 95% del total del país. Este
porcentaje ya cayó al 65%. Ante el declive de
PDVSA y la caída de los precios del crudo, Maduro
buscó una alternativa: un plan para reactivar el
sector minero de Venezuela. ¿Queréis saber de qué
estamos hablando? Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2(EL ARCO MINERO DEL ORINOCO)
El sector minero nunca tuvo gran importancia
para Venezuela. Maduro quiso que esto cambiara
en 2016. Para ello decretó la creación del Arco
Minero del Orinoco. Se trata de un territorio en
el sur de Venezuela con forma de media luna y del
tamaño de Cuba. Su objetivo era atraer inversiones
para la extracción de oro, hierro, cobalto,
bauxita, tantalita, diamantes y otros minerales.
Obviamente, la nula seguridad jurídica que ofrece
Venezuela ahuyentó a los posibles socios. Todo
ha resultado ser una sombra del gran proyecto
anunciado por Maduro. Actualmente, la mayor parte
de los recursos minerales están siendo explotados
por mafias ilegales que actúan con impunidad.
¿Con cuánta impunidad? Pues la suficiente para
disponer de esto para sacar el oro del país.
N3(La minería ilegal montó sus bases
aéreas en la selva. Armando.info)
Esta investigación indicó que los contrabandistas
utilizan al menos 42 pistas de aterrizaje
clandestinas. También se cree que el 91%
del oro de Venezuela se produce de forma
ilegal y que posteriormente se transporta
hacia los países vecinos. Por este motivo
no hay cifras creíbles de cuanto oro se produce
en Venezuela. Los planes de Maduro eran producir
alrededor de 80 toneladas de oro anuales para
2025. Sin embargo, en realidad, la producción
probablemente ya esté cerca de este número.
Pero claro, el problema es que la mayoría de las
minas y de las rutas comerciales están controladas
por bandas criminales. Una vez más podéis
haceros a la idea de toda la riqueza que pierde
el Estado venezolano al no tener un control fiscal
sobre estos recursos. Pero esperad un momento,
porque hay cosas aún peores. La minería ilegal
utiliza mercurio para extraer el oro del mineral,
lo que está teniendo consecuencias letales.
(Es un negocio también del régimen; es la venta
del mercurio para hacer minería ilegal. Y entonces
este mercurio pues está quedando en los ríos
y está envenenando a no solo los mineros;
también a los pueblos indígenas que
viven en los alrededores de estas minas.)
(SOS Orinoco estima que hasta el 70% del
curso del río Caroní, el segundo más grande
de Venezuela con casi 1.000 kilómetros de largo,
está en riesgo de contaminación con mercurio.)
Los pemones, el principal grupo indígena de la
zona, presentan niveles de mercurio superiores
a los considerados seguros por la Organización
Mundial de la Salud. Y el medio ambiente es de
nuevo una víctima de lo que pasa en Venezuela.
La minería a cielo abierto que se practica es muy
agresiva con el territorio. En los últimos 20 años
la deforestación alcanzó unos 3.800 kilómetros
cuadrados de la Amazonía venezolana, el 1% del
total. Y la tendencia va a más ante la difícil
situación por la que atraviesan los venezolanos.
(Los salarios se han derrumbado en la Venezuela
de Maduro. Muchos trabajadores ganan menos de
10 dólares estadounidenses al mes. Así que la
minería ilegal se ha vuelto muy atractiva dada
la ausencia total de alternativas. Decenas de
miles de personas, en su mayoría hombres, se
han mudado para probar suerte en este trabajo.
La minería ilegal también se ha convertido
en la única vía de subsistencia para muchos
indígenas ante el desplome del turismo.)
Estos mineros no tienen salario. Se quedan
el 40% del oro que encuentran y el 60% es para
el propietario de la mina. Los mineros pueden
cambiarlo por efectivo en los campamentos pero
a un precio reducido. Por desgracia este no es
el único abuso que sufren estos trabajadores.
La ONU ya constató en un informe los constantes
abusos de derechos humanos que se dan en la zona.
Para colmo, la minería ilegal está controlada por
grupos armados como el Ejército de Liberación
Nacional de Colombia y facciones disidentes de
las FARC. También por grupos criminales como
el Tren de Aragua o el Tren de Guayana. Y os
aseguro que no se andan con rodeos para
hacerse con los recursos mineros. Mirad:
N4(Desmantelan campamento con armas de guerra
del «Tren de Guayana» en Bolívar. Por supuesto:
todas estas mafias operan con el visto
bueno de los peces gordos del régimen,
las autoridades regionales y los oficiales del
ejército bolivariano. Todos ellos han recibido
sobornos de los grupos criminales, en una zona
donde el Estado ya ha perdido el control total de
la situación. Las mafias campan a sus anchas.
Mirad el mapa del parque nacional Canaima.
(Según SOS Orinoco, hay hasta 27 áreas
mineras en el borde del parque, muchas
en el río Caroní y otras 32 en su interior.
La situación es tan preocupante como triste.)
Venezuela, un estado que fue pionero
en Latinoamérica en la protección de
espacios naturales, es hoy incapaz
de proteger su medioambiente más
preciado. Y más de uno estará pensando,
¿hay alguna forma de contrarrestar el
ecocidio venezolano? Pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T3(SUSTO O MUERTE)
Poco se puede hacer
desde fuera de Venezuela para frenar el ecocidio
que está teniendo lugar dentro del país. Una de
las fórmulas que más adeptos tiene es la de
clasificar el oro extraído en Venezuela como
oro de conflicto. O al igual que se dice con
el tráfico de diamantes, como oro de sangre.
Desde luego no faltan los motivos para hacerlo:
la minería ilegal de Venezuela está generando
una importante ola de violencia en las pugnas por
su control en el sur del país; está enriqueciendo
a grupos criminales; y también está llenando
los bolsillos de sus gobernantes corruptos.
Por todos estos motivos,
Estados Unidos ya sancionó
al sector aurífero venezolano hace 4 años.
Sin embargo amigos, hay dudas de la efectividad
de este tipo de medidas. Es improbable que
las sanciones y las prohibiciones detengan
el comercio del oro de sangre venezolano y
posiblemente favorecen que su mercado continúe
aún más en manos criminales. Por todos es sabido
que hay grandes cantidades de oro de sangre que
escapa de Venezuela por las fronteras con sus
países vecinos. Allí se suman al inventario
de exportadores autorizados, que posteriormente
envían el oro a las refinerías más importantes del
mundo. Esa es la realidad: sabiéndolo o no, estas
refinerías están comprando oro de sangre. Y el
caso es que, por una u otra vía, el rastro del oro
venezolano llega a los lugares más insospechados.
(Irán contrabandea oro venezolano
para financiar a Hezbolá. Iranintl)
Difícil elegir, ¿verdad?: si sancionas el oro
venezolano, acaba financiando a organizaciones
terroristas; si no lo sancionas, estás dando
oxígeno al chavismo. Susto o muerte. Por una
situación similar ha atravesado el petróleo
de Venezuela. Como os contábamos antes,
Estados Unidos sancionó el petróleo de PDVSA
a raíz de la crisis presidencial de 2019. Lo
que nadie pudo imaginar es que Estados
Unidos se viera interesado en suavizar
posturas ante el régimen de Maduro. El motivo:
como os podéis imaginar: la Guerra de Ucrania.
El interés de Washington: el crudo
extrapesado de Venezuela para suplir
al crudo extrapesado que antes traían de
Rusia. Mirad lo que se anunció en noviembre:
(Chevron reanudará la producción
de petróleo en Venezuela mientras
Estados Unidos alivia las sanciones. FT)
Actualmente Estados Unidos está importando
100.000 barriles diarios de petróleo venezolano.
A cambio de que Washington haya autorizado estas
importaciones, el chavismo ha reanudado las
conversaciones que se celebran en México con
la oposición. Apenas se han producido avances
en el terreno político y desde Caracas ya están
pidiendo el fin de todas las sanciones impuestas
por Estados Unidos. Veremos cómo evoluciona este
asunto, pero desde luego, no se puede decir lo
contrario: estas son buenas noticias para Maduro.
De hecho, el Palacio de Miraflores podría ser una
fiesta de no ser por el enésimo escandalazo que
asola a PDVSA. Un escandalo del que ya os hemos
hablado hace muy poco tiempo aquí en VisualPolitik
en un vídeo que os dejo en la descripción.
Antes veíamos el titular: una auditoría
ha descubierto que la petrolera estatal acumula
21.200 millones de dólares en facturas pendientes
de cobro durante los últimos tres años. En otras
palabras, PDVSA aún no ha cobrado el 84% de sus
exportaciones de petróleo desde 2020. De hecho,
ya se cifra en 3.600 millones de dólares la suma
que posiblemente nunca se cobre por tratarse
de operaciones con intermediarios poco fiables.
El presidente de PDVSA en este período
ha sido Asdrúbal Chávez, el primo del
expresidente que fue ascendido por Maduro de
forma meteórica. Fue cesado por el presidente
venezolano el pasado 6 de enero. Pero esperad un
momento, porque las cabezas siguieron rodando:
(Ministro de Petróleo de Venezuela
renuncia en medio de investigación
de corrupción de PDVSA. Bloomberg)
Está siendo un comienzo de año muy
movido en PDVSA. La nueva gerencia se
está dedicando a revisar los contratos
de la petrolera y a endurecer las condiciones de
prepago para su crudo. Todo esto ha provocado que,
a pesar de que el país esté consiguiendo
incrementar su producción de oro negro,
las exportaciones hayan disminuido ya que
las embarcaciones están siendo retenidas en
los puertos venezolanos sin poder zarpar hasta
que se confirma el pago del zumo de dinosaurio.
(Si se hacen las inversiones precisas, la llegada
de efectivo a PDVSA es la única forma de que el
incremento de producción de crudo no venga
acompañada de más derrames. Del mismo modo,
mayores exportaciones podrían mejorar
la situación de la economía venezolana y
reducir la importancia del sector minero. Podría
ser, por tanto, un incentivo para combatir la
minería ilegal y ofrecer alternativas,
como proyectos agrícolas o turísticos,
a muchos venezolanos que actualmente ven la
minería como su única forma de ganarse la vida.)
Una buena gestión de PDVSA parece imposible
mientras continúe el chavismo. Pero un escenario
sin el régimen de Maduro al frente no parece
realista actualmente. Por tanto, el chavismo
vive en una crisis permanente. Pero vive. Ahora os
tenéis que pronunciar vosotros. ¿Hace bien Estados
Unidos en volver a importar petróleo de Venezuela?
¿O creéis que Biden está dando oxígeno al régimen
corrupto de Maduro y está actuando contra los
intereses de la oposición venezolana? Podéis
dejarnos vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Si el vídeo te ha resultado interesante dale a
like y no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik si
aun no lo has hecho. Un saludo y hasta la próxima.